[Musica]
era il 2009 ero in viaggio e per la
prima volta vidi una rappresentazione
del mondo simile a questa cartina
geografica
il mondo veniva presentato attraverso un
punto di vista diverso dal mio come
vedete l'europa non era nel centro e
personalmente mi senti un po persa e
questa sensazione di disorientamento
iniziale fu seguita dalla curiosità
volevo capire se la se la gente del
posto vedeva il mondo attraverso la
stessa inquadratura
e così durante il viaggio chiese da
alcuni locali
alcune persone del posto di descrivere
il mondo attraverso un disegno e questi
sono alcuni dei disegni che colleziona
ii durante il viaggio e come vedete lato
e nel centro non solo se focalizzate
l'attenzione magari potete anche
indovinare dove mi trovassi guardate
bene ero in giappone
come vedete è il punto focale di tutti
questi disegni e non solo e nel centro è
il più grande ma anche il paese più
definito
guardate il dettaglio e questo esercizio
mi incuriosì così tanto che negli anni a
seguire ho continuato a raccogliere
mappe del mondo disegnata memoria e
attraverso conversazioni
interessantissime e vari viaggi ne ho
collezionate a centinaia
non è assolutamente un catalogo
scientifico ma mi permette di osservare
che tutti quanti raccontiamo il mondo
attraverso la nostra esperienza
il creatore si mette nel centro e in
base a ciò che decide di includere nella
mappa o mettere ci racconta che cosa
importante per lui e per lei
questo no b
mai più di una raccolta di mappe e una
raccolta di storie
e queste storie oggi mi permettono di
introdurre il mio argomento come
possiamo andare oltre all'anno nostra
storia alla nostra mappa
come vedete da questi disegni ognuno di
noi ha una percezione del mondo
individuale
in altre parole non vediamo la realtà
così com'è ma la vediamo attraverso il
filtro dell'esperienza
e dati sono uno degli strumenti capiamo
però per andare oltre questa percezione
soggettiva
sebbene anche i dati siano soggettivi e
abbiano dei buy aspetta ovviamente sono
creati da persone
sono uno strumento
incredibilmente accurato della realtà
che ci circonda e quindi lo possiamo
usare per avvicinarci alla complessità e
per navigarla
ma i dati a livello grezzo sono
incomprensibili
hanno bisogno di una voce ed è questo
che faccio nella mia professione
dare voce ai dati perché i dati non
parlano da soli
il mio lavoro e il design
e consiste nel creare esperienze che ci
portino alle storie dietro i dati e
questo linguaggio prende varie forme si
plasma sulle storie che voglio
raccontare ma anche su chi voglio
raggiungere mi vedo come un ponte tra la
sorgente e il pubblico
ea volte è come vedete da questa
raccolta queste forme sono stati che
altre volte interattive e altre volte
addirittura sperimentali l'abbiamo
portata in opere teatrali
l'obiettivo è che i numeri non rimangano
numeri ma che le storie arrivino perché
vedete c'è questa tendenza di pensare ai
dati come un materiale asettico come
numeri e basta
qualcosa che non ci rappresenta per gli
esperti
ma per me i dati sono un materiale
veramente creativo che mi permette di
esplorare il mondo di stazione la mia
curiosità e poi di esprimere le mie
scoperte
come definizione un dato è una
descrizione elementare della realtà e
queste descrizioni le possiamo trovare
in qualunque cosa facciamo in qualunque
speri anche ad esempio guardare un film
questa è la decostruzione del famoso
film di kubrick shining
analizzando la struttura ed alcuni
elementi visivi ho scoperto attraverso i
dati che ad esempio il colore e
strumentale nella narrazione
guardate ad esempio queste due scene
hanno tanti elementi in comune a livello
stilistico ma ce n'è uno che prevale il
colore appunto
soprattutto quando ci rendiamo conto che
queste due scene sono state girate in
due bagni verde acceso e rosso brillante
sono alquanto inconsuete come scelte
cromatiche e quando riportiamo queste
scene all'interno di tutta la
sceneggiatura a livello cromatico
effettivamente sono atp che vedete
kubrick non aveva lasciato niente al
caso e anche colore diventa uno
strumento narrativo per dirci che c'è
qualcosa che sta succedendo qua jack il
protagonista sta perdendo la testa
seviziando a comunicare con il
soprannaturale
questo è potere dei dati di farci
tornare all'esperienza iniziale con più
consapevolezza con più conoscenza e
apprezzare la realtà che c'è attorno a
noi per andare oltre alla nostra
percezione
però oggi non voglio
raccontare di come re raccogliamo i dati
ma piuttosto di come li comunichiamo
e quindi vorrei portarvi un po nel mio
lavoro e voglio usare due progetti a me
molto cari per raccontarvi di come
traduciamo i numeri in esperienze di
storytelling
il primo progetto è tratto dal mio libro
di infografiche of the world
abbiamo creato cento infografiche che
narrano l'evoluzione del mondo e
l'evoluzione dell'uomo e ogni
fotografica parte con una domanda
investigativa in questo caso per questo
per questo esempio la domanda di
partenza è alquanto complessa qual è
stato l'impatto della guerra nel
e impossibile rispondere in maniera
conclusiva ovviamente a questa domanda
ma nei dati possiamo trovare uno spunto
per descrivere la complessità della
realtà
e la fonte scelta in questo caso ci
offre una lista di di conflitti la
durata dove sono avvenuti e soprattutto
sacrificio umano quante persone sono
morte in ogni conflitto
poi decidiamo che lei si cosare
ovviamente non scriviamo con parole ma
scriviamo con immagini
e questo lessico e visivo e in questo
caso
sfruttò quello che è il pattern back
nations ovvero come il nostro cervello
riesce identificare dimensione
proporzione
distribuzione delle forme astratte
e la semiotica ovvero il significato dei
segni e delle immagini e in questo in
questo contesto uso il papavero come
simbolo di commemorazione caduti alcuni
di voi magari staranno pensando alla
referenza al papavero nella canzone di
de andrè la guerra di piero
bene il paese in cui vivo l'inghilterra
il papavero un simbolo nazionale di
commemorazione ai caduti
simboleggia la speranza per la vita e la
pace ma al tempo stesso con il suo
colore rosso il raid poppi ovvero
papavero rosso ci riporta al campo di
battaglia a vedere il sangue versato sui
campi
e questo il risultato
un paesaggio commemorativo in cui dati
hanno una voce visiva
la linea del tempo inizia nel 1900
anni conflitto è rappresentato da un
fiore è ancorato a terra nel momento in
cui la guerra inizia l'altezza
rappresenta la durata e sboccia per
indicare il sacrificio umano
come vedete nella prima metà del
novecento ci sono due guerre che hanno
causato milioni di morti
la prima e la seconda la seconda guerra
mondiale
ma è nel secondo
nella seconda parte del secolo che le
guerre si sovrappongono e diventano più
lunghe ce n'è una che addirittura copre
sette decenni
israele palestina
e soprattutto quest idea che la seconda
parte del novecento sia così caotica ci
porta oltre alla nostra storia
ebbe nella forma interattiva di questa
infografica possiamo anche mettere a
confronto due storie l'occidente il
nostro mondo e il resto del mondo ed è
qui che il veto a design ci può portare
oltre alla nostra storia
ad ampliare la nostra visione del mondo
quello che spero di fare con il dito
design dando voce ai dati e creare
empatia
per andare oltre a quella che è la
statistica ma per ricordarci che dietro
questo paesaggio dietro questa mappa ci
stiamo delle vite per raggiungere
elementi arrivare al cuore
questa per me è la grande sfida del mio
lavoro
ricordarci che dietro i grafici dietro
le statistiche ci sono persone e di
questi tempi che ovviamente
di dati ne abbiamo sentiti a bizzeffe e
grafici sono strumentali
per capire la complessità del nostro
mondo e in questi tempi di pandemia sono
diventati una bussola
mi sono veramente posta questa domanda
come possiamo andare oltre a queste
rappresentazioni per ricordarci che
dietro ogni grafico ci sono delle
persone
ci sono delle storie umane
e all'inizio di quest'anno collaborando
con il museo di londra abbiamo cercato
di dare una risposta a questa domanda
nuovamente molto complessa e che
nuovamente non può avere una risposta
conclusiva
qual è stato l'impatto del virus nelle
nostre città e in particolare nella mia
città londra e questa è la mia risposta
un video un film allontanandoti
microscope che cerca di ripercorrere un
anno che nessuno di noi ma si
dimenticherà il primo anno della
pandemia
è impossibile raccontare le storie di 9
milioni di londinesi ma ciò che ho
voluto fare è creare un contesto
condiviso che potesse poi essere
navigato in maniera soggettiva
e questa mappa è stata ricreata
mettendo assieme la geografia di londra
e quella che è l'immagine visiva del
virus sfruttando un po la biologia della
struttura del virus e prendono
appiattire la realtà reinventando la
mappa ho deciso di codificare vari
livelli di complessità quindi abbiamo la
mobilità nel trasporto pubblico sulla
membrana abbiamo i casi le morti e
abbiamo anche i vaccini e poi un
contesto editoriale che ci ricorda gli
eventi
ea questi dati abbiamo dato una voce
visuale ma anche una voce sonora per
creare veramente un contesto più
viscerale che ci riporti a quello che è
stato il primo anno della pandemia non
mi posso far sentire tutto il film ma vi
vorrei far percepire un estratto i 30
giorni che precedono e seguono
all'annuncio del terzo l'ok town a
londra
come vedete qua
abbiamo i quartieri di londra
ogni quartiere un picco che rappresenta
i casi
e queste particelle che mai come ogni
giorno su di morti mentre si dissolvono
vanno ad accumularsi nel background
che cambia la scena
[Musica]
come da significato qualcosa di diverso
per ognuno di noi e quindi l'emozione
che viene generata guardando questo film
sarà soggettiva e individuale ma quello
che spero il progetto faccia e
ricordarci che oltre alla nostra storia
c'erano tante altre storie quindi quello
che volevo fare non era quello di creare
una risposta conclusiva ma piuttosto di
portare un contesto condiviso e creare
uno spazio di riflessione
con questi due progetti spero che vi
abbia potuto raccontare quello che è il
mio obiettivo nel mio lavoro la mia
ricerca quella di farci sentire chi c'è
dietro ai dati per vedere oltre al
numero
per farci sentire le implicazioni e per
ricordarci appunto che se conosciamo in
queste conosciamo i dati se conosciamo
queste storie ci possiamo sentire più
connessi alla realtà che ci circonda e
penso che il design possa veramente
apportare un bagaglio di riflessioni e
di emozioni ai numeri ma per veramente
risvegliare i nostri sensi a quella che
può essere definita
un'anestesia nei confronti dei numeri
penso che il mio lavoro non basti il mio
lavoro ha bisogno di tutti voi
collettivamente bisognava guardare il
mondo con occhi più curiosi continuare a
chiederci il perché delle cose e magari
cercare nei dati delle risposte ma anche
pensare in maniera critica questi dati
invece di estrapolare una statistica per
confermare il nostro punto di vista
ricordarci che
anche se non siamo direttamente
rappresentati ci possono essere altre
storie e quindi guardare al mondo con
compassionevoli perché vedete prima di
diventare un numero in una tabella o un
puntino su una mappa
siamo delle persone
visto che oggi chi
informazioni ne avete sentite tante di
dati ne abbiamo sentiti tanti proviamo
con un'esperienza risvegliare i nostri
sensi proviamo a vedere se riusciamo a
creare una mappa assieme
ho bisogno della vostra partecipazione
ed è il momento di usare cordino
creeremo una mappa tutti assieme
sarete voi designer
ok
voglio prendere in prestito i vostri
occhi curiosi le vostre menti critiche
ai vostri cuori compassionevoli e
cercheremo di dar forma l'amore con
questo cortino prendetelo da un capo
e pensate a cosa significa l'amore nelle
vostre vite può essere una persona più
persone poi stringendo
un momento che magari vi ha cambiato la
vita e vorrei che me lo lega sta al dito
scegliete voi la mano e il modo in cui
lo legherete al video magari il numero
di volte l'intensità quanto stretto lo
stringe o se volete farci un nodo un
fiocco rappresenterà la vostra storia
siete creativi non c'è forma giusta o
sbagliata
e poi vorrei che portò se l'altra mano
all'altro capo
e adesso vorrei che alzasse tutti quanti
le mani e avvicinate quanto più le mani
vicino possibile alle persone che vi
stanno a fianco così che saremo un
network
siete bellissimi e bellissimo vedermi
ok abbiamo appena dato forma ad una
storia invisibile
certamente non possiamo leggere le
storie individuali di ognuno di noi ma
ne possiamo percepire l'intensità perché
ci abbiamo appena messo il cuore
ed è proprio questo il mio invito
nuovamente a non perdere di vista le
storie umane che ci sono dietro un
cordino una mappa un grafico perché solo
così i dati si possono connettere
perché come abbiamo visto oggi
abbiamo la scienza la tecnologia
abbiamo il design e le arti visive a
dare forma ai dati ma è solo quando
queste forme queste voci incontrando la
nostra umanità e noi ci sentiamo parte
della stessa mappa che allora i dati non
rimangono mera informazione ma diventano
conoscenza e la conoscenza
generazione
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]